[音楽]
皆さんは
金縛りにあったことあるでしょうかそう
金縛りです金縛りとは主に就寝中でている時ですね
意識がはっきりしていいのかな体を動かすことができない症状サス体が締め付けられる
ような感覚からこう呼ばれています話針
金縛りはもういろんな原因があると言われてますね霊的なものがあるしてその疲れて
たり
は精神的なものとかで寝てる時に
急に来るんですよ僕も一定金縛りにあったことがあってなんだけどなんか正しく哲也
tetsuya から徹夜してて朝寝たときになんか体が疲れきってて寝るんですよ
普通にでなんか体が動かなくなったなぁと思って目を開けるんですけど
目を開けてても体が動かないし声も出ないみたいな
でもなんか品
ってパニクっちゃってやばいって思うすめっちゃ怖かったです金縛りまあ俺ぐらいの
スーパー色になるとな金縛りなんてに化けてちゃダメなんだよ
強い今日は金縛りよ疑似体験してみようと思います
訓練だね実際に彼は縛るようで体験して俺それうち約れなきゃいけないんだ
自分の力ねー
相手で今回のゲストの皆さんが6デブさん達です
いないシャツはホラー
今日は自分の手で金縛りの空間をつくります話張って先説明あったんだけど意識はある
状態で体が小柴られるような感覚に襲われています金縛りになったことある人はわかる
と思うんですけどめちゃくちゃ強いんですよ
一人で動画とるぐらいだしたらそのままボが
金縛り&も全然怖くないからね余裕だよマジで
まずまずプレイヤーは
[音楽]
ブーブー
ん
頭よしよしなんとが出来ましたん
背景でここからですね僕の金縛りの物語が始まります
今日は全部レンズ面向いてるね僕がくほう
このころころってこのがって僕が誤審ってこう
金縛りにあいますさん縛りから抜け出せればもうクリアって感じでね
まあサクッと行ってきますよやっぱり最強だからさここに感謝られたかマジ余裕なん
ですよ
うん
思っ
はいええええ
[音楽]
ここでは誰かがいて
ええええええ
ています
[音楽]
can
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ん
[音楽]
yeah
ええええ
ねえええええええええええっずっ
[音楽]
ってちょっと待って待って待ってこんなはずじゃないなんて
ちょっとなんて持ってません
ちょっと待ってますので
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーバーし
ああああああああ
[音楽]
ラジャー
じゃあ
a
[音楽]
ね待ってくっついてくるんだけど
どうぞついてくるんだけど